this came out
uh i am starving i haven't had lunch
since yesterday so i'm gonna head over
to callahan's
oh no no don't go there they totally
skimp on pickles let me go to bighead
joes for you
they have the most insane burritos i
don't much go for ethnic food
trust me they have one that's called the
meat tornado
literally killed a guy last year you had
me at meat tornado
who the hell is forp i don't know i
couldn't really hear him
it sounded like his name was for get his
number no
good girl ron swanson april ludgate
hey i'm just going to pop over to grain
and simple to get the very best
ingredients for my burger do you want to
come
what is grain and simple it's a health
food store
pawnee doesn't have a health food store
no but snurling does and it's only a
40-minute drive
what are you doing andy i'm getting
healthier snacks for the shoeshine stand
chris is a food genius
did you know that the food you eat
becomes energy yeah
boom that's spaghetti nachos
it's a cookie that's my husband
there's so much free food at this party
honey i love politics look
i made a shrimp claw i'm really proud of
you babe
i'll put your used plate in my purse i
almost have a complete set really oh my
god you're so smart
how about the new sushi place in
eagleton i'm allergic to sushi
every time i eat more than 80 sushis
that barf yeah
nothing warms the blood like a little
whirly bat with the old butter jar hey
leslie
indeed this guy's tougher than i thought
i don't know how either of you guys are
doing this one time my refrigerator
stopped working i didn't know what to do
i just moved i just don't think he's
ever gonna quit he has that look in his
eye that ben gets when he plays risk
oh wow that is really good andy no i'm
sorry
this tastes great all my favorite foods
have butter on them pancakes
toast popcorn grapes oh
buttery's my favorite food well then
you're gonna love what i'm turning up
take a look at oh my god this is
horrifying nobody eat that
william elizabeth leslie hi hi
what are you are you coming to see me
did you hear that i'm relaunching my
campaign
actually no sorry we weren't here to see
you we've been meeting with other
potential candidates for city council
oh really so my campaign ends and just
like that you find someone else and run
theirs
yes that's our job i know good luck
but uh i just had a big meeting with my
new advisory board
and they're brilliant and amazing
they're real killers
leslie i tried to make ramen in the
coffee pot and i broke
everything thank you andy i'll be right
in well
uh good luck leslie honestly well we
don't need luck
we are a rocket ship we are relaunching
and we're gonna blast
past your cannon huh they're done this
couldn't have worked out any better
there was a guy eating lunch in here
didn't finish his spaghetti
oh also tom and lucy are totally gonna
fall in love
five second rule i made a marshmallow
ron swanson
[Music]
gosh his arms are crossed because he's
mad at all the other marshmallow workers
for annoying him
you like it it's fine when
i was trying to decide how to decorate
my office i had to ask myself
what kind of candy should i choose
obviously chocolate
cause i'm sweet smooth and the ladies
love me now the questions still remained
what kind of chocolate am i do i have a
little gooey caramel center
am i filled with little rice krispies
maybe i'm white chocolate and i'm
bucking all the stereotypes put your
damn candy out
ultimately i decided to go with little
gourmet fudge
i didn't have time to make it into
anything and please don't eat it because
it costs 55
an ounce so i made my desk out of silver
m ms but they do not make silver eminem
so i spray painted them okay those are
poisonous so no one eat them
yeah duh go throw up i didn't eat any go
throw up
[Music]
you really shouldn't have dug that out
of the dumpster i had to
also i had a banana on the way over here
sorry
i get why you don't want anyone to know
about duke silver and you don't have to
worry
your secret is safe with me to even it
out
i'm gonna tell you all of my secrets oh
no that's
not necessary i once forgot to brush my
teeth for five weeks
i didn't actually sell my last car i
just forgot where i parked it i don't
know who al gore is and at this point
i'm too afraid to ask
when they say two percent milk i don't
know what the other 98
is what's this
dragon fruit what's this
a kiwano or horned melon what's this
a peach i knew that
wow fresh lettuce is my all-time
favorite food
what's your favorite food oh i take
skittles and i put it between
two starbursts you know what i call it
skittle sandwich
that's pretty good no i call it andy's
mouth surprise
it's nice because the the flavor of the
starbursts really bring out a
similar flavor in the skittles
fork
fork morning roomie how'd you sleep
well there were no bed bugs also no bed
i'm gonna go buy a bed fork i'm sorry
are you eating turkey chili off of a
frisbee
it's pretty cute right no do you know
what cute means
what have you got against turkey chili
for breakfast what have you guys got
against washing dishes
we don't have any dishes okay burly took
them all when he left
now i bet you feel like a jerk
oh yeah ten bucks
that kind of making the lotteries okay
now is this
the most amazing grilled cheese sandwich
ever made
um that's pretty awesome honey my bucket
list doesn't say make
a pretty awesome grilled cheese sandwich
gotta go back to the store we're gonna
get a different kind of cheese no
dude seriously this is the most amazing
grilled cheese sandwich ever made okay
okay what's next new dish we're working
on tell me what you think
it's a red and white heirloom red bean
pasta with an imported tuscan walnut
herb sauce infused with shaved heritage
pecorino romano what you're done
really good why are you doing new dishes
uh lucy
is visiting her boyfriend conrad in
chicago
so i'm just trying to distract myself
with work so i don't think about the
marathon bone sesh they're probably
having
we spent like 50 hours working on those
burgers we know
hard work never pays off cooking is dumb
i swear on this dead crow that i will
never cook for you
you